[Musique]
euh,
les vidéos que vous venez de voir sont toutes de faux
sauvetages d'animaux, malheureusement, ces vidéos sont
toutes conçues uniquement pour le divertissement, ce sont donc des
animaux sauvages qui ont été
détenus en captivité et conçus pour
servir d'accessoires pour ces
vidéos choquantes sur YouTube qu'ils
montrent  des signes clairs de
blessures physiques avant même l'attaque donc coupe le
sang et les blessures um
dommages à leurs
ailes et plumes coupées c'est un
nouvel engouement inquiétant c'est un phénomène énorme
une seule vidéo illustrant le sauvetage d'
un varan de
l'
attaque d'un python avait été  visionnées plus de
100 millions de fois
[Musique],
vous pensez peut-être que ces vidéos semblent
réelles, mais il y a des signes évidents
qu'elles ne le sont pas, ce sont clairement des vidéos de scène
car la qualité du tournage,
elles sont toutes dans les mêmes paramètres, donc elles
peuvent l'être  sur une berge sablonneuse par exemple
le fait qu'un homme va
encore et encore rencontrer
cette situation où il y a un
prédateur dans une situation de proie qu'ils
sont là pour le sauver les chances
que cette situation se produise dans la vraie vie
c'est que ce n'est pas crédible  souvent, les vidéos
seront tournées plusieurs fois, ce qui
causera probablement de graves traumatismes psychologiques
et des blessures à ces animaux
et potentiellement des décès également, bien
que les animaux soient finalement
sauvés, ils montrent clairement des signes de
détresse et de panique et vous trouverez des
images pénibles de singes paniqués
désespérément  essayant de se libérer
des emprises du python, les rapaces et
les bezepre qui sont décrits comme des
prédateurs dans les vidéos ont souvent
des ailes coupées et ils atterrissent maladroitement
et ils ne présentent pas de comportement naturel de prédateur,
mais avec les
problèmes de bien-être des animaux, il y a aussi
préoccupations de conservation car souvent il y a des
espèces en danger critique d'extinction et en voie de disparition qui peuvent être vues dans
ces vidéos qui ont été utilisées comme proies
et prédateurs comme le crocodile siamois
et aussi le la gibbon la popularité de
ces vidéos est également une grande préoccupation
des 50 plus  visionné des vidéos, ils ont
été visionnés plus de 130 millions de fois
ces animaux sont exploités uniquement
à des fins de divertissement, donc depuis l'écriture sur
youtube
et depuis la publication de nos
conclusions, certaines des vidéos ont été
supprimées et supprimées, mais la grande
majorité est toujours disponible et
visible publiquement  aujourd'hui, nous demandons donc
au public de ne pas
être au courant de ces fausses vidéos de sauvetage d'animaux
pour savoir qu'il s'agit de fausses
vidéos de sauvetage qui exploitent des animaux, nous
demandons au public de ne pas partager ou
aimer ces vidéos et de partager nos
médias sociaux  content de faire passer le mot
que ce sont de faux sauvetages qui exploitent
des animaux que
vous